مره جديده تقول قوه فاجنر الروسيه انها
اقتربت من تطويق مدينه باخمت الاوكرانيه
بالكامل المدينه التي ارتبطت اسمها باطول
معركه في تاريخ اوروبا الحديث بعد الحرب
العالميه الثانيه القوات التي تقود
المعركه في باخمت نشرت صوره توضح
السيطرتها على خمس مدن جديده في محيط
المدينه وقالت انها تواصل المعركه حتى
السيطره عليها
بالمقابل يواصل الجيش الاوكراني التاكيد
على ثبات قواته في باغموت حيث تشير اخر
الصور القادمه من هناك الى انتشار الجنود
الاوكرانيين في مواقعهم بكامل معداتهم
واجهزتهم الحربيه
والتكنولوجيا وفقا لاحدث المعلومات القوات
الروسيه سيطرت على جميع الطرق المعبده
التي تؤدي الى باخموت مما يعرقل بشكل كبير
امداد الوحدات الاوكرانيه في المدينه
كانت فاقدر سيطرت على الجانب الشرقي من
المدينه ليصبح النهر الذي يقسم المدينه
الى نصفين خط المواجهه المباشره بين
الطرفين
كذلك اعلنت قوات فاجنر في وقت سابق عن
افتتاح 58 مركزا للتجنيد في المدن الروسيه
فيما يبدو للدفع بمزيد من المقاتلين في
المعركه المصيريه بالنسبه اليها وموسكو
ومع استمرار القتال على جانبي النهر يستمر
الجانبان بالتراشق بالمعلومات والصور
معلومات ما زالت غير مؤكده حتى يثبت العكس